how are you
are you hey you look incredible
too what's your secrets
lavender bags
and you smell good
how you feeling look at that
um great yeah this is for you baby
I'm great really good yeah yeah yeah I'm
I'm um yeah the the night is winding
down and um
um the show is still going the show won
White Lotus like right after you you
made Mike cry he got up there and had to
give a speech I mean there was a lot
well
he's a very good speech Giver he did I I
did see a clip of him saying it and he
and he
he's very funny in it he did say some
very funny things did you know that you
made him cry I didn't because his table
was not he wasn't at my table oh got it
so I didn't and I couldn't really see
him from the
but hey if I can make my My Cry
I I feel like that's that's an honor and
I hope I can do it again okay you know I
gotta ask and I hope I can make him mad
too
is there any chance at all that you can
come back again
I don't think so I mean I don't know I
mean he might you know you never know
would you do it
okay good okay okay yes of course if he
could figure out but I don't know you
know there's talk I don't know how he
would do that but
but I'm game yeah you were saying you
know I mean you've had just this
Resurgence of a career I mean we've
loved you forever but you've had this
what what do you what has it been what
do you think it's been and what is like
the biggest call you've gotten like jobs
or opportunities or that kind of thing
I kind of blame the the this generation
this new Young Generation for sort of
bringing me back I feel like Ariana
Grande Put Me In Her video and that sort
of changed you know like she you know
that changed a lot for me over sort of
overnight you know um
I I blame I blame her and um
I don't know maybe people are just like
she's still alive
[Laughter]
we'll give her a salute or something
because you're so freaking funny in fact
I just saw a shotgun wedding I'm
actually interviewing you tomorrow oh
yeah
oh my God we should just like go out on
the town and we just come back in our
addresses tomorrow I say yes we could
just you can come spend the night at my
house
okay let's toast to you hey thanks and
just you know I just want to say this um
if you do see me in this dress tomorrow
all right don't tell anyone
[Music]